hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast RNA targeting CRISPR and
application to diseases presented by dr.
J neo principal investigator professor
UCSD we are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual agents and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning find Julie simmer off of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the seee button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Jayne yo I will now
turn the presentation over to him is
targeting our nature being by
Christopher Cass and I will go over some
of the project that we are using this
application for technology board okay so
like just to give you a rough idea of
what my lab is doing here's some
background I'm not interested in
studying RNA processing and
possessing as you can see here is the
the process by which RNAs are modified
and matured after being transcribed from
genome and for the most part RNA is then
transported to the cytoplasm and
translated into protein
now RNA processing is diverse and there
are many aspects of RNA processing
ranging from splicing polyadenylation
small RNA processing and biology RNA
transport the cave or editing and
assemblies of protein RNA complexes and
so my lab focuses on the discovery of
mechanisms that underlie underlie RNA
processing as well as the regulatory
networks that are controlled by proteins
RNA binding proteins that bind and
process RNA the other part of my lab
worked on strategies to manipulate RNA
processing using a variety of different
technologies and throughout through the
last decade of the work in my lab in
this field we have been applying and
developing novel computational molecular
and fellow tools to aid our process and
understanding RNA processing so just to
move ahead here some background on our
recent work in the you know efforts in
large-scale analyses of RNA processing
so RNA processing defects underlie a lot
of genetic and somatic diseases in
humans and you're just some examples are
not comprehensive but a good repertoire
of diseases that are not caused by
altered learning biology now again just
as a reminder we study how RNA is
process and the biggest class of
proteins that control our new processing
are called RNA binding proteins there
are many many RNA binding proteins are
encoded in the human genome and they
combine and
direct me to RNA the control how RNA is
modulated there is a rather complicated
figure but comprehensive one from Tom to
Joseph's lab that shows the many aspects
in the RNA can be processed and bound by
RNA binding proteins so just to remind
us again RNA binding protein play
critical roles in development and
mutation or alteration on RNA binding
proteins cause human disease by altering
RNA processing pathway as a reminder
also these RNA binding proteins exert
their effects by interacting with short
since regulatory elements that are
encoded in mRNA or pre messenger RNA and
these are short since arbitrary element
can be sequence specific recognition
elements or it can be RNA secondary
structure motifs they're embedded within
the RNA molecule now by binding but by
binding to this short story element RNA
binding proteins can mediate a variety
of the different RNA processing tasks
however currently the functions of the
majority of RNA binding proteins are
still understood and the precise RNA
targets which are bound and regulated by
these RNA binding proteins are largely
unexplored and from early studies in the
field we expect that the majority of RNA
binding protein can interact with
hundreds if not thousands of different
RNA substrates so we have been
continuing to improve methods to
identify the precise binding sites or
RNA binding proteins as a way to build a
map for what did RNA binding proteins
can be doing we have leverage
technologies such as clip first
developed in rock Darnell's lab in
Rockefeller and clip stands for
cross-linking IP America's petition
where you be crossing proteins to RNA
and digest a way or the unprotected RNA
and then use antibodies to emit a
precipitate the RNA binding protein RNA
complexes and then like if adapters to
specific RNA molecules that are that are
protected by the by the antibody by the
proteins and then sequencing the
footprint over at the RNA binding
protein fine so as you can see here on
the on the Left these are products of
leads that correspond to specific a
specific RNA binding protein binding
site tdp-43 so we have been developing
computational methods to analyze
large-scale sequencing data sets and are
also developing new ways to improve
these methods to enable large-scale
analyses of RNA binding protein function
now we know that there are 1,500 human
antibodies and that's probably a lower
estimate you know we and others are
finding new ones all the time so there
must be better ways to evaluate all
these RNA binding proteins more
systematically and also at a had a pace
in which we can then study more biology
related to this RNA binding proteins so
over the last year my Latins published
several publications that illustrate our
efforts in what we call scalable
analyses of RNA binding protein for
example on top well we have been
expanding the list and repertoire of RNA
binding proteins by developing
algorithms and mind existing
protein-protein interaction datasets to
identify RNA by novel RNA binding
proteins in cleanser least blind humans
we also been developing antibody
resources for the large-scale study RNA
binding proteins and here we have
manually validated about 700-800
antibodies specific for different RNA
binding proteins and identified about
438 antibodies which are IP gray
antibodies for about 400 something RNA
binding protein and these have now been
made all publicly available where you
can search for your favorite antibody
that we have already validated using as
the journey is an IP followed by Western
blotting on the bottom left you can see
we've also developed enhanced or more
robust put methods where we can reduce
the number of PCR duplicates and on the
on the these are violent plots at the
bottom where each dot corresponds to
downloaded data sets or quit sequencing
representing depend on binding proteins
and the y-axis is the usable fraction of
weeds weeds Beeker are useful and are
not simply PCR duplicates and so you can
see on the blue dots on the left that
our enhance clip or a clip that is able
to generate datasets which much higher
usable read fractions about 85 and 90%
on average then existing datasets
represented by the public eye clip and
public datasets and finally we've been
developing integrated computational
analyses to combine different data types
and different technology needs to help
us make sense of what RNA binding
proteins are doing and just summarize
over the last five years now we have
worked very closely with our labs of
bread gravy Chris birch sounds on flu
Marylou PA to amass a large datasets
about a thousand replicated data sets
that measure different aspects of RNA
biology this dataset represents 352 RNA
binding proteins of which 23 percent of
them have no known function and so we we
again integrate methods such as RNA seek
generated by Brendan grip his lab on a
mine and seek which is a form of selects
generated by Chris birch chip seek by
channel 2 and then even a fluorescence
in all datasets generated by a loop in
his lab and our own data sets include
data set for RNA binding proteins that
together enable us to understand the
localization of our BP's the RNA
dependence of our any regulation but
it's RNA binding proteins and to give us
some new ideas about the function of our
bees this is a largest data set of RNA
binding proteins since i'm at systemic
collector to date everything is publicly
available on the encode website in and
in genesis generated in this two cell
lines k562 and empty - as an example of
what the eclip or mapping is our VP's
can be useful for so here here one
example is equipped businesses for a
different RNA binding proteins and then
28 B RB box - p8e - we have two and a
year 251 these different RNA binding
proteins bind to diverse places on the
same RNA transcript and the the peaks
are the high numbers of leads tell you
that that they bind very specific places
but also places which are unique to the
different RNA binding protein so for
example IDF to beat one bind to the
three prime untranslated region opens
gene whereas RB [ __ ] - for example binds
to intro neck regions flanking
exons within the same gene what can we
do in this maps so we are very
encouraged by by the fact that last year
a drain cleaner
effort across from Harvard to study the
splicing of this smn2 gene has enable
Ionis pharmaceuticals in pub and Belgian
to develop and descent oligonucleotide
therapy for spinal muscular atrophy and
so in spinal muscle atrophy loss of
function of smn1 needs to a reduced
level
SMN protein through tendons to spinal
muscle in Turkey now in humans another
copy of the gene smn1
is present called SMM - however
smn2 is ultimately spliced where one
exon is not included in the majority of
the smn2 mature mRNA and so it does not
produce the correct or sufficient SMN
protein so what Adrienne and colleagues
have found is that you can develop and
assess all the nucleotides that block
the binding of an RNA binding protein
ancient Rapa one from binding downstream
of this particular exon number seven I
believe in s Emma - and by blocking
anyone from repressing exon usage you
can reverse the splicing to generate a
90% of the correct full-length isoform
and this leads to the increase in SMN
protein thereby curing a spinal muscular
atrophy
we believe that these RNA binding maps
that that we and others are generating
can serve as a potential basis for
rational drug design where you can use
the maps to decide where specific RNA
therapeutics can be targeted to such as
MIT senescence all the good nucleotides
I'll get shifting gears I will now move
towards talking about the manipulation
of RNA processing instead of discovering
the maps and where our VP binds you so
for the past now part five to ten years
there have been many studies in the
literature using different RNA binding
domains to engineer and trying to
manipulate RNA in living cells so you
can imagine that RNA binding domains
within existing RNA binding proteins
have been volved to recognize specific
sis regulatory elements and sequences
now I can then construct combinations on
these domains to then target any RNA
sequence you want that is a dream and
and the the best example of this is the
proteins where several labs have now
assembled different domains in the
popular teams to recognize structures of
eight or more bases in RNA molecules now
if we can engineer RNA binding domains
to bind our names but in places then we
can recruit effector domains to
manipulate the RNA this will have
tremendous importance and flexibility in
being able to understand RNA processing
but also as potential therapeutics now
we were very excited when the CRISPR
caste 9 for example complexes were
discovered over there identified because
if you look at tailings and zinc fingers
they're analogous to what the fuel has
been trying to do with proteins which is
you assemble proteins to bind to
specific nucleic acids
however the Chris broadcast 9 technology
at now enable a programmable a
recognition a far more efficient by
using a cast 9 protein and
guy RNA do you recognize specific DNA
sequences so we envision that we could
do something similar programmable RNA
recognition by now targeting the CRISPR
caste or other caste proteins to RNA
instead of DNA and you can fuse the cap
protein to different effector domains
then you should have the ability to
engineer
transcriptomes as a proof of concept
that this can be this can work in vivo
we collaborated with Jennifer doubtless
lab where shown into a 14 that you can
use a Pam all eager murmur DNA oligomer
to trick the caste 9 protein to now
recognize RNA and you can design
components of the pan and Pember and the
guide RNA do not harbor dyes to specific
messenger RNA sequences and thereby
targeting the cash protein to RNA in
vitro now in in the collaboration of
Jennifer we decided to see if this also
works in vivo in live cells and there's
a proof-of-concept my student babe
Nellis in the lab used GFP to a nuclear
localized cast 9 and this protein is
dead so it does not have the Cadillac
neat active site which cuts DNA so we
reasoned that if we can design and
modifications of the pammer and as your
RNA to hybridize to express mRNAs in
human cells or live cells then GIP caste
which is normally nuclear will follow or
track with the mRNA into the side of
button and and here's the the proof
so as exciting data we can see on the
top left of the of the boxes here that
with that with
a targeting guide our name and the
targeting hammer that recognizes that
the MRNA the normally nuclear localized
cast nine GOP on the bottom right it's
now now moving from the nucleus of the
cytoplasm
that's it on the top left and so this is
quite exciting because it gives us the
first example that the CRISPR cast night
system can recognize endogenous mRNA in
live cells in the programmable fashion
so this was published in cell 2 or 16
and in my lab we decided to then push
ahead with the technology to see whether
we can identify other RNA sequences and
activate different activities in them so
we started looking at microsatellite
associated diseases where their expanded
DNA repeats in coda in the human genome
but in patients with different
microsatellite diseases such as federal
extramural sorts in the syndrome at CAA
and other diseases these repeats are
expanded to lines far beyond what we see
in normal patients so in this talk I'll
focus mainly on myotonic dystrophy 1 and
932 so the em1 and em2 so in DN 1 yeah
these expansions of CGG repeats in the 3
prime UTR of the gene near PK and in DM
2 you have a slightly differently p CC
TG we just expand it in an intron of a
different gene now in both of the
diseases it's been quite well
established that these aren't these DNA
repeats are expressed because they're
within genes which are coding genes are
expressed but they are expressed and
because they are expressed and they're
so repetitive and expanded they
sequester
different proteins that bind RNA this
sequester these proteins to these
repeats
so for example at the bottom here you
can see that muscle blind 1 2 & 3 are
sequestered by these expanded repeats
away from their normal targets where a
muscle blind normally affects splicing
and thereby you had this disrupted
splicing in the cases in cells of
patients with myotonic dystrophy and
these repetitive sequences are so hot so
expressed and because of there's a
repetitive that you can do RNA fish
which is the image on the left in the
nucleus and see that this repeats are in
its RNA full side now we rationalize
that we should be able to make an impact
in studying myotonic dystrophy but maybe
even helping to reverse some of the RNA
toxicity that's derived on these
expanded RNA repeats now my tendency is
a new terrible disease it's a it's a
disease of muscle but also CNS and brain
patients can have cardiac conduction
defects and also cataracts and there are
congenital versions of yem as well so we
try to use our cast 9 the RNA charging
cast fused to gfp again to target these
repeats in cells transfected with to see
eg expansions without the targeting
guide and targeting pan a little more
arc s9 localization is diffused but if
we have targeting guide to the repeats
and trying pammer we're able to localize
cast 9 and GFP to the same places where
the RNA post IR as you can see on the
second row where the world whole of life
now surprisingly probably because of the
repeat expansion that repetitive nature
of the expansion we do not require the
use of the pam oligomers and we're still
able to co localize cast 9 2
Arne repeats now the next step we were
inspired by a study by gentlemen's lab
and we used this pin and the nucleus
domain are now fused to that cast nine
and we envisioned that this and the
nucleus would brought close to these RNA
close I will lead to the destabilization
on this RNA profile now in our study
because my alone can be say blood on
cosine but the pin enables us to achieve
this at much lower doses so the the
bottom row here you can see with the
white arrows that cells expressing high
levels of decays nine with pin and you
can visualize this with an antibody
recognizing the H a happy to fuse to
dicuss nine pin so in green high levels
of Deacons my pin you can see on the
second column that in green that the in
the left column then you have a lower
levels of correspondingly lower levels
of the RNA full side you might hit it
and read by RNA fish so this is an
indication first indication that our
test nine can can lure RNA both side all
these micro satellite with repeat
sequences we can also show that this is
true for different repeats such as CCU G
or the mdm2 and GGG GCC or AMS we can
quantitate this in in by cloning number
of cells which contain pitch fish signal
normalized to the repeat only signal and
you can see therefore for many different
repeats including CG which is present
Huntington's we can lower unit number of
cells within competitive sequences now
just just to show that these are RNA RNA
dependent we have used a construct which
is dogs inducible where
upon treatment of doctor cyclin you can
use GOP on one side of the construct and
then on the other side you can drive
part of the dmpk gene encoding about a
thousand CGG repeats in the three prime
UTR which is the same obviously as the
m1 now we can then stop doxycycline and
so RNA RNA and ictap are now transcribed
and present in cells but after stopping
doxycycline there's no more
transcription on these RNA or the GOP
but they are present in the cells
already and we can then transfect in you
know he casts nine the pin and get Iron
Age trying to repeat the show that he
can destroy or reduce the full size
independent of transcription and these
are just ways of quantitating that
number cells but also the polls change
over ducks or negative thoughts finally
we can also do this in patient cells so
not distance like the cells but patients
myoblast from patients with the m1 and
then the row at the bottom you can see
that installs that express dicus type in
a JTAG you can reduce the RNA cosine
relief at low in vivo at low doses the
pin fusion can degrade RNA much more
efficiently than he can die without in
even though Nick s9 by binding believe
can unravel the RNA structure and make
available endogenous processes to lower
the RNA profile now we also know that
muscle blind protein can co-localize
with the repeats in himself from dm1
mice mice models and so we wanted to
know if we can destroy the repeats can
be redistributed not supplying proteins
better than normal organization states
so here showing that muscle blind
normally is in
you clear the beautiful slightly lower
side of has made localization pattern if
you express repetitive sequences muscle
bond is sequestered to the repetitive
sequences and co-localize in this RNA
fish image that's right
let's call them and and then if you can
treat the cells they are cast nine
targeting the repeats and you can now
achieve redistribution of muscle buying
back to the normal or localization now
one would imagine the in you can reverse
muscle blind localization then you can
also revert alternative splicing
patterns such as present on the left
here where different bands showing the
context of forms then you can see in the
muscle blind inserting the BM one maja
blast from patient's CDG targeting guide
RNAs can restore the the aberrant
splicing patterns from the non targeting
one back to the normal control outside
ones this can be looked at also using
large-scale RNA sequencing and may be
best to summarize globally across all
the different isoforms and within the
genes in genes that we can measure each
dot on the top left represents a percent
splice in or hex on the inclusion of
specific exon in bm1 patients different
from control and there are lots of dots
there their current also excellent it
explains differently we've removed the
ones in the middle diagonal which are
not different and in the bottom bottom
row we treat with a CPG targeting guide
and the same doctrine but are now moving
to the in the middle showing that we can
reverse transcript my splicing and this
is true both in my glass and myotubes
and which is very exciting because these
are the downstream more like the markers
for there are reversible to the disease
and so this paper was published recently
in cell to showing that we can use only
targeting CRISPR casts to ameliorate
microcell I repeat extended diseases
but this is all itself so what about in
Bebo so recently in collaboration with
James Thomas in Molly Swanson's lab we
have generated vectors encoding it's not
pin and RNA turning repeats and these
are packaged into AV viruses and
injector contralaterally in mice models
of bm1 expressing the c CGG repeats and
we can show that in vivo we can also
reduce the RNA close i and muscles
injected with v viruses these treatment
and reduction of the pause I also revert
downstream also blind one mediated
splicing defects as you can see upon the
the pin and targeting guide treatments
now in the first row all the artificial
images that is a reversal splicing like
the wall type of the power channel gene
which actually restores the correct
protein abundance of poet channel which
is now represented in green by the email
fluorescent images on the right in
tissues we can also show that we can
reduce ever in my my own nuclei the
among my smaller tissues and finally
reversed transcript on white splicing
feedback that's war in people so we're
very excited because we think that this
works in vitro in patient cells in vivo
in nice and there are many other things
that we can use
rnh are being transferred which I'm
happy to elaborate on but personally to
thank the folks in the lab that didn't
work right and so clip and encode
related projects have been largely led
by Eric I'm not sure and a postdoc a
talented postdoc in my lab together with
gave me bro Pratt scrub the student and
supported by by implementing staff as
well as a team a dedicated team of
clippers that perform these experiments
Steven and Balaji and so on
for the irony trading cast work we have
Dave and Nellas and Ron Batra now that
that told that the word for em1 and em2
and together with vibration with kevin
Corbett Maurice Watson and I'm happy to
thank the rest of my group and thank you
for the invitation and I'm happy to take
questions
thank you very much thank you dr. Yeoh
for that informative presentation it's
time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
tuck your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question we will
followup with an with you via email
after the presentation let's get started
our first question is our RNA binding
sites preserved on the same mRNA and
different tissues that's a good question
so in the encode project we had math or
any binding sites for many RNA binding
proteins in two cell lines and
evaluating the comparing RNA binding set
for the same RNA binding protein both
cell lines we find that many of these
sites a majority of them are actually
preserved however when we move to other
tissues and probably more relevant
issues and other cellular states say
neurons or embryonic stem cells we find
that there are other RNA by increasing
they are not expressed obviously in in
the lines that we have on the previous
encode experiments these RNA binding
protein and new sites
they also RNAs are expressed in a tissue
specific manner Richard now present
which
all busy also have new sites and so I
think that that a lot of work needs to
be done for mapping RNA binding proteins
in a variety of different different
systems and tissues thank you what is
next for these large-scale RNA binding
protein mapping projects so we have
continued to now increase the number of
reagents antibodies and also tag lines
or other RNA binding proteins we want to
expand you list of mats for more anybody
proteins but also across as I mentioned
more tissues and cell types and I think
what's also very exciting is to be able
to map these RNA binding proteins in a
different in different cellular states
so for example cells that are treated
with different stressors what cells from
cells are emoto's for aging for example
cells from diseased patients patients
with mutations in RNA binding proteins
cells in cancer cells undergoing chemo
therapeutic you know treatment for
example and so that all these all these
different states may help us think about
how the RNA masks are changing over time
and may give us better indication of
which target RNAs can be interrogated or
disease manipulation
thank you what are the advantages of
using RNA targeting CRISPR versus DNA
targeting CRISPR so the differences
between using our new target CRISPR and
the an attorney CRISPR definitely relies
on the application so DNA targeting is
currently used for working the lab or or
you know potential in vivo their therapy
ex vivo therapeutics rely on DNA repair
and many post mitotic cells neurons also
do not really have efficient DNA repair
and so our networking does not rely on
being built in this DNA repair machinery
and it's able to manipulate and destroy
or or change RNA processing which are
the downstream downstream of the gene
sequence encoded in genome on the other
advantage of RNA targeting is that the
off target rated it's presumably quite
different so in in DNA targeting
particularly of these markets that
repeat expansions
there are many of these repeats pilling
across the genome and one would envision
that if the any cutting happens in many
repeat sequences in the 3 billion base
pairs in the genome you would have a lot
of aberrant cuts which may lead to
chromosome abnormality and and other
issues wears off where's the the Arnie
on target earth or constrained to the
express and relevant set of RNA in the
south side and also the the on target
sequence that were the expression of the
abundance of the RNA that were targeting
maybe hundreds to a thousand copies more
than men off target RNA worsen DNA it's
it's pretty much the same copy number
between off and on and off target
so there are other advantages as well
but these are the two main ones great
thank you
next question is what are the major
challenges to using RNA targeting casts
to gene therapy
the main challenge to using RNA charting
casts or gene therapy applications I had
to do the immunogenicity of the protein
and this is an active bacterial protein
and and we'll we'll be in in some cases
energetic and so being able to humanize
or modify the protein engineering cat
protein it's a it's a opportunity but a
major also a major obstacle to getting
this to work in Cantera p the other
challenge is delivery but this is a true
also for other gene therapy applications
we're getting the protein in the right
cell and having a new room have a
durable response for a long long period
of time and getting in that would be 13
in as many thousands we need to that's
that's always going to be I mean for now
a challenge in the gene therapy to
expect
thank you we'll wrap up with one last
question and that question is what are
other potential applications to RNA
targeting CASP
so Arne targeting castes can be used to
reduce as I've shown the levels of toxic
RNA but it can also be used to change
the translation of mRNAs like splicing
like RNA editing methylation
localization of RNAs and so it all
depends on the effector domains that my
life has a lot of experience with RNA
binding proteins to modify the
functional RNAs and and so there are
many potential applications for basic
research also there are therapeutic s--
by modifying RNA and and i think also in
the space of reagents in every culture
where one would want to target or be
able to visualise RNA or alter the or
destroy viruses that affect plants and
so on so there are many many potential
applications to RNA targeting cats I
would like to once again thank dr. Yeoh
for his presentation do you have any
final comments no thank you for your
body for the opportunity and I'm happy
to
[Music]
thank you once again dr. Yeoh i would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go i want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through december
28th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available to replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues in the admits to days leggett
inch that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye